for now we go back to the white house
peter ducey is standing by there he's
got some new information for us as this
is playing out what's happening peter
and brand new shannon i actually haven't
had time to read this in full yet but we
just got a readout basically a
description of the contents of a call
that just wrapped up with president
biden and the ukrainian president
zielinski so i'm going to read this to
you now president silenski reached out
to me tonight and we just finished
speaking i condemned this unprovoked and
unjustified attack by russian military
forces i briefed him on the steps we are
taking to rally international
condemnation including tonight at the
united nations security council he asked
me to call on the leaders of the world
to speak out clearly against president
putin's flagrant aggression and to stand
with the people of ukraine tomorrow i
will be meeting with the leaders of the
g7 and the united states and our allies
and partners will be imposing severe
sanctions on russia we will continue to
provide support and assistance to
ukraine and the ukrainian people now
even though the images that we've seen
on
the
on our
many different feeds that are coming in
from ukraine are very dramatic
especially given the build up over the
last couple of weeks with this we are
told that president biden is not under
any circumstances going to send american
troops to ukraine to fight russians
something else that was missing from
that readout of the call is consistent
with what a senior administration
official told me tonight and that is
that president biden and zelinski
tonight did not discuss what had been
reported recently which is that u.s
officials
according to some recent reports we're
actively trying to figure out a way to
convince zelensky a a good way to leave
the country if this happens that is all
absent from the reporting so for now
based on what we're getting from the
white house zolensky is going to stay
that's also consistent with what he put
out in that instagram video uh the
president in his statement about this
call also says that they will be
imposing sanctions
i spoke to a white house official a
senior administration official tonight
and asked if given what's going on
tonight tomorrow will be the rest of the
sanctions the full package they've been
saying that they were keeping some back
just in case putin did something really
aggressive and i'm told that tomorrow
whatever they announce will not be the
full package because with something like
sanctions you can always go and add more
but one of the things to be on the
lookout for because this senior
administration official tells me there
will be some significant ones in there
we should look to see if tomorrow is the
day that the united states sanctions
vladimir putin personally that would
basically isolate him financially from
the entire rest of the world that and
that is something that as recently as
this afternoon
shinsaki in the briefing room said is on
the table so
sanctions have been the response so far
putin was not deterred he is continuing
on the action that they have been
warning about for weeks we expect more
sanctions tomorrow and white house
officials are betting that with the
weight of the sanctions and the weight
of the united states with
european leaders behind them putin will
back off shannon
all right peter ducey thank you very
much so